[Music]
and he started it news submitted by
shark Steve footage shows the social
media star named brother nature as the
aggressor in a violent fight I saw this
[ __ ] I heard about it but I didn't know
what happened I didn't know who brother
talked to like pigeons in New York and
feedback yeah so that's how he became
really so he's known as like this really
sweet nice guy who's very like gentle
with nature he's like hood Steve Irwin
you can trust me look at that smile like
it reaches his eyes it's reaching his
eyes look at the natural occasion
there's a great smile smiling all right
yeah nice hairline [ __ ] oh it's okay
it's not bad no I just want so far
Chicago okay so this happened in Miami I
mean when this first surfaced I will
show you two video clips the first one I
will show you the clips that surface and
I went viral and a lot of people were
very concerned for brother nature and
saying like what the [ __ ] no one helped
him he's just getting you that beat like
what the hell
[ __ ] up yeah so I'll show you that
first so you guys could have the same
the same timeline as like the public
perception here BAM
yeah he's going with the checkered chain
oh you'll see now remember what surface
[Music]
all right that's what everyone what he
just got his ass beat already got no
[ __ ] I was weird so they stopped of
that everyone immediately jumped on
mr.brother nature side and said like oh
he got chomped and you know everyone
shame shame everyone for not helping and
this and that him basically they saw him
as a victim and then the next video came
out oh yeah oh yeah oh that was included
okay
yeah chemo and like Joe said exactly
everyone was just like what the [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] up and then so they were
able to find out or find the guy who was
beating him up and he did an interview
and so he was saying that this is the
situation that actually went down so it
turns out that Kelvin brother nature's
real name is Kelvin he was at this
sandwich shop really late at night it
was like right before 6:00 a.m. and
we're like early in the morning I guess
so the sandwich shop was letting
everyone know like hey this is last call
and they put up like all the seating
area like all the chairs were up but
they had already cleaned everything so
they said hey you know we're about to
close you can still order your food you
could still eat your food but you have
to eat it at the bar here but then
that's when Kelvin was just like he was
tripping he was just like no I want to
sit there like give me a waiter and like
he was just being all like don't you
know who I am kind of [ __ ] oh yeah
brother naturey
an [ __ ] so then that's when this guy
who goes by
mr.brother ass so this guy he goes by
Dee the guy kicked his ass they gotta
keep the vest
so Dee ends up pulling out his phone to
record Kelvin being an [ __ ] about the
whole seating situation so he's
recording him and then this woman or
this girl that was with Kelvin catches
Dee filming and tell tells Kelvin like
like instigating pretty much saying like
hey what the [ __ ] he like he's recording
you aren't you gonna do something about
she's Puerto Rican for sure record ocean
I passed and there be a little [ __ ] I'm
not sucking your dick tonight that won't
make a do fight yeah so that's one
Kelvin goes up he goes up to Judy he's
like give me your phone and then put
this phone down on the counter he's just
like what the [ __ ] are you gonna do like
you don't know who I am kind of thing so
then that some Kelvin was like let's go
take this [ __ ] outside so then they do
and then that's what we're about a
sandwich that's not important right now
something so that is pretty important
though that's when they end up going
fine you never got it okay so someone's
just laying that somebody took it yeah
maybe they didn't even make it at this
point cuz it just all happened when he
was ordering you know who knows before
he goes outside though there's a pivotal
moment that's recorded where brother
nature goes to two of the guys and goes
dead man dead man yeah and then he walks
outside so then I have that clip which
is gonna be in the second one so yeah
it's like as they're going outside is
when he he I don't even know how they
were able to obtain whatever he wasn't
on that record Kelvin recorded this
himself and then they end up going
outside that's when G kicks his ass and
that's like the outside footage here I
saw and then I like you tell me he told
him let's take this outside that he
wasn't even fighting part really cuz he
just like grabbed onto his shirt he
ripped his shirt
so like he was just [ __ ] and heavily
intoxicated or doesn't know how to fight
I don't know but then that's when D goes
back into the sandwich shop and then
that's when Calvin comes back in and
then this is what you're gonna see to
actually I just let you see it I guess
yeah okay this is the most highly
anticipated sequel or the pre-core this
is the prequel record recorders like
that without the permission here we go
and then it comes up people want to
delete that yeah yeah that's when he why
don't you look at delete a video for me
this is DS cousin so cut the cut
those involved hey man don't [ __ ]
disrespect me like that you don't know
who I am
alright let's take it outside then
that's when he runs like they do the
outside thing
Oh so I oven comes in and bum rushes he
was sitting down he got his ass beat
outside and then he came in he came back
and introduced the catches yeah to
sucker punch one of the other guys and
you got jumped again he beat is it so
bad he started fighting somebody else
thank you let me go you still get
revenge
no that's [ __ ] I think in the UFC yet
the guy gets knocked out and the ref
stops and the guys I'll try to grapple
the rest but I wish because it was just
about to bite into yeah so brother
nature has been as far as I know silence
on this whole thing the old actually the
only thing he did end up tweeting out
was something along the lines of like I
know there's a video of me getting
jumped and no-one doing anything like
shaking my head or something like that
he thought like exactly before CCTV
footage came out so he was still trying
to be a victim oh yeah wow what a
[ __ ] faker well that's the problem
with people that start [ __ ] right they
don't know that they're actually
starting [ __ ] and if they get [ __ ] up
and all right where was everyone yeah
this world is coming to an end what if
he was getting past me and all kinds of
[ __ ] animals came in
[Music]
he's like he calls them no [ __ ] up or
crackers like nature's call he's not
really brother did he like a Bambi Bambi
watch this footage and they're like oh I
need to tack him calls coming the
[ __ ] wolves come they all [ __ ]
join forces and he's all like beating
him up and then he's like oh [ __ ]
I see the whole forest there Jim like a
bunch of wolves yeah the [ __ ] little
squirrel is that told you yeah yeah
[ __ ] out he's trying to flex like
that's a if you could turn your head
backwards would you ever face anything I
would never face anything I would just
always do this dude they didn't have his
back though - [ __ ] they're like yeah
so then what ended up happening was
after that whole altercation the
sandwich shop called the cops but by
then everyone had already left and the
sandwich shop ended up reporting it as
self-defense so like in terms of like D
so DS bill yes he came in to attack his
friend so I think that was self-defense
but then the soda and the kicking the
head I don't know if when he's on the
floor he was thirsty because he maybe
was cooled down his anger with the
[ __ ] soda sheets you got cottonmouth
I want to know how they got this video
from Kelvin he plays like on this story
you're talking and they took it out
video was his buddies of him saying that
man
like what did you upload that they had
to be drunk they had to be drunk so
there's like a ad hello hello before you
leave they take this airdrop real quick
to drop what does the won't did the
woman to anything maybe he got hit that
night though cuz he did do something
about it he did my back like that's not
I did hear something else though about
the situation like where he was eating
with this girl and then the guys were
like oh [ __ ] that's brother nature and
then he was like recording without the
permission and she was uncomfortable so
he came up and he was being extra macho
about it that's the that's good there's
so many ways he could have gone by it he
didn't have to be macho about it he
could have just been like hey went to
another he's brought the night she go
get anywhere man go to Subway like juicy
yeah I mean he could he could have just
said like hey man can you delete that
but you had to be such an like a tough
guy a bad word thing go well he's not in
the wrong that much but still like the
footage already just proves it that he
was he was in the wrong yeah he was he
challenged his dude yeah you you gotta
stomp somebody out like that yeah but
she was threatening not [ __ ] him that
night so that was that was death yeah I
was told that on a date I'm like where's
the Gatling gun I'm just shooting
everybody down
that's Jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]